we had this comment come in on our
channel in a horror movie Only the
villain Character Matters all the other
characters are expendable most are going
to die anyway what's your reaction to
that well
um I disagree
I would say with that I think in a movie
every Character Matters
you know you want to build good
characters across the board if you can
build a good villain character that's
fantastic because a throwaway villain
character is not good for your story
just a straight villain you know you
want that villain to have motives you
want that villain to have some kind of
connective element those always make the
best villains
but you want to lead character to root
for and in a horror movie
you know it's it's it's somewhat of a
Russian Roulette you don't know who
hopefully you don't know who's going to
get killed I mean there's definitely a
lot of cliches and horror films a lot of
80s cliches which I always think is
interesting that even nowadays like
people still use 80s cliches instead of
90s or 2000 cliches if that even exists
um 2000's more about the torture porn
element of horror with just uh brutal
violence and and graphic uh Gore and
whatnot
but I mean
every movie needs good characters
totally uh even horror movies I mean
every movie so you want to connect with
someone if you can connect with if you
connect the most with the villain
that's fine you're connecting with
someone and maybe you think the
villain's right
a lot of people watch The Avengers and
like oh Thanos had a good point it's
like you know you want your villains to
be dynamic and so if you can make a
horror villain that's Dynamic that's
really impressive
especially one that's
you know like a Jason Voorhees who was
done wrong you know he lost his life due
to someone else's incompetence he yearns
for his mother who killed in his name
like he he has all these different
reasons why he's doing things it's not
like he just shows up and start slashing
people for no reason
um Michael Myers was one where they he
had good reasons for a while but now
it's kind of
just like a hack and slash kind of a
thing but when you can make your your
villains Dynamic is is awesome
so I don't necessarily think that every
character is a throwaway character
there's definitely some low budget
movies that don't pay as much attention
to that and just think oh if I follow
this simple formula then it'll be good
because it's a horror movie people die
there's blood you're happy and it's like
well not always and that's why there's a
thousand of those that don't go anywhere
or don't reach cult status because
they're not good
um but I mean every movie needs good
solid characters all across the board
what are some of those classic 80s
horror cliches not 90s or 2000s but they
sure what do we see the 80s the 80s
definitely brought us where it's like
you have your very distinct characters
here's your jock guy here's your sexy
girl here's your nerdy guy here's this
person has some kind of your Stoner
character or someone that does drugs
uh which is really funny because I love
I really want to do a slasher movie with
modern tropes where it's like oh here's
your yoga instructor here's your your
vlogger uh here's your host your Airbnb
host yeah here's your Minecraft beta
tester or something uh but you all you
have those consistent characters whereas
nowadays those
well people still sort of fit those
types in reality it's so much more
across the board there's not just a
football player you know you might have
a football player that loves playing
Dungeons and Dragons you might have a
nerdy guy who just made a million
dollars with his crypto I mean there's
there's so many different Avenues
nowadays that it's kind of interesting
that people really focused on those
types of tropes
and uh like they made a movie uh like
scream which ironically scream they came
out in 1996 from Wes Craven that was the
movie that made me go into filmmaking
because it talks about all these tropes
and it pulls back the curtain on the
thought process that goes into movie
making and I'd never really thought
about it until then that really opened
my eyes to be like oh there is a lot
more to movies than just stuff happening
like these all these decisions are made
really specifically
and so with 80s tropes it's like oh no
you know this is going to happen and
that caused you to die a big thing was
the AIDS epidemic
so in Halloween and Friday the 13th
they're like oh if you have sex you get
killed because of the time people were
dying from AIDS and that was a really
big fear in the country and so they took
advantage of that to be like look this
is scary you know nowadays to be like oh
no this this one's going to lose this
401K it's like oh that's like terrified
you know well Social Security is not
going to be here anymore you know or you
lost you lost all your Bitcoin you lost
your Bitcoin Drive something like that
um what about 90s tropes what about 90s
horror 90s ended up reimagining the 80s
tropes and making all of the the
characters very intelligent you know
scream kind of kick-started that genre
of filmmaking usually every decade in
horror there's a movie that kind of
kick-starts and reinvigorates the
franchises in the 90s scream did that
and so then all of a sudden you had new
slasher movies like I know you did last
summer urban legend or like there's a
killer but all of our kids are totally
smart they're on computers they have
cell phones like they're totally hip
with the world around on them they make
references to pop culture you know these
are these kids are smarter now than they
were back then where they're just like
hey let's go smoke up behind the barn oh
no he's got a machete you know that's
kind of how the 80s were we're in the
90s everyone's smarter so they're all
they're all running better because they
were they're more aware self-aware and
then in the 2000s you get into the Saw
movies and hostel where it's just about
brutalizing people and just graphic
torture which I was never really into
because I'm like it's boring you know
that's boring that's not smart it's just
kind of I know this person is stuck in a
trap and it's like all right
um
nowadays I don't
I don't even know oh paranormal activity
in Blair Witch Project was a huge boost
too in found footage horror because
people were kind of like oh man they
made Blair Witch Project for sixty
thousand dollars and they sold it for a
million dollars I can make a million
dollars if I run around with a camera in
the woods and so then all of a sudden
you get a thousand of those kind of
movies and a lot of them are not done
well I mean that that's a total needle
in a haystack movie nobody could have
bet that that movie would make so much
money and be as impactful as it was and
it is scary like because they pitched it
as being real
and I remember driving two and a half
hours three days in a row to the nearest
theater playing it in 1999
because and I took friends the next two
days so I'm like you have to watch this
movie it's incredible it's going to blow
your mind and it's and you watch it
nowadays and I still think it's
impactful like I still get you know
jumping in and getting nervous and
anxiety because it's just such a real
visceral experience
and then the rise in reality of
Television after that I mean you
suddenly get Survivor and all these
other reality shows and that now that's
a huge boom Market because the studios
first off are like oh this is really
cheap we don't have to put anything in
visual effects we have to pay all these
people like there's people running
around with the camera this is fantastic
we'll make a ton of money and they do
and that's why we have like 100 reality
shows now
um but horror constantly reinvents
itself because eventually themes outstay
their welcome and someone figures out a
new way to tell a historian the great
thing about horror is that the entire
world can relate to it every single
person dies every single one of us on
the planet so everyone on Earth can
relate to trying to stay alive because
we all have to you look at like an
American Comedy like I remember when
American Pie came out and they were like
oh they sold this movie overseas for
nothing it's like well yeah because
there's probably a lot of communities in
Africa that aren't worried about getting
some in high school like they can't
relate to that it's not doesn't connect
as well
but horror Sci-Fi Action sci-fi every
single one of us has stars over our head
it connects us all and action like
everyone wants that that big ex you know
explosions and escapes and everything
so there are a lot more connectivity to
those types of movies than there are for
dramas
or comedies and things like that
how do you think some of the Stephen
King films have evolved over the decades
because a lot of them had this broader
message
you know they weren't just scares and
different you know some of them are gory
obviously but there was usually a
broader message yeah
Stephen King's stories
Stephen King's a fantastic writer I mean
his books are so visceral and so deep
and so thick my wife's a huge fan of
Stephen King's we have a ton of his
books and the movies of Stephen King
started really really strong everyone
was like Carrie and The Shining I love
Christine personally there's a bunch of
those movies that came out Pet Sematary
I really enjoyed
um
and then eventually they started turning
them into television and I think that's
when it started getting watered down
we're like we can make a six hour mini
series based on the Stephen King book
but it has to be rated PG
and so then it's kind of like other than
it
uh the original it which was still very
impactful the other ones start getting a
little more watered down and they're not
it's all made for television so you
can't really keep all the themes with it
and it's like oh here's the Tommy
knockers and The Langoliers and all of a
sudden you're like I don't rose red and
you kind of lose that after a while
and nowadays they started like they
brought it back and they remade it which
I really really enjoyed because they
made it more of a a fun
fun movie that's still scary but it's a
lot of fun to watch
um
they made his movie Cell which didn't do
very well I mean a lot of his stories
are very hit or miss with film you know
a lot of them are internal a lot of
internal things happening in the
character's heads and it's really
difficult to translate that into a movie
I think the last one was Dr sleep
the sequel to The Shining and I thought
they did a really really good job in it
but it's just not it's not ever going to
be that original movie especially at the
time period when that came out it was
such a more much more of an impact than
if you had brought it out today I think
what was the one where it was about a
tabloid journalist
The Dark Half okay where he he flies
and then he oh the Night Flyer yeah the
NightFire yeah he's a vampire right but
then he there's a well I don't want to
give it away but then there's like this
other ominous pilot and that the Two
Worlds Collide yeah
I think it's the Night Flyer okay he has
a little Cessna that he like goes around
and they keep fighting and he's bitter
and he's using these bars and he's just
writing these horrible tabloid stuff but
yeah he stumbles Upon a Crime and yeah
okay that was and there's a lot of I
mean the Mist is really well done
there's a lot of them that are well done
there's a lot of them that all right
they just remade pet cemetery which I
like the original one better
um the new it I really enjoyed though I
did enjoy that a lot
and there's just so many Gerald's Game
was good Netflix did that one that
wasn't even good
um but I feel like it's kind of hit or
miss with his stuff because the books
are so involved and so mental that it's
hard to kind of portray that as easily